so rudy giuliani appeared on ABC's
program this week with George
Stephanopoulos and he seemed to I guess
inadvertently unless it's part of some
campaign to deliberately so confusion
which it very well may be Giuliani
appeared to admit that Donald Trump
obstructed justice by asking James Comey
than FBI director to give indicted
national security advisor Michael Flynn
a break in the Russia probe and Rudy
Giuliani insists out of one side of his
mouth that there's just nothing to see
here
but then he admits that well yeah the
President did say specific things to
James Comey about how to handle the
Michael Flynn situation which would be a
way of in a literal sense getting in the
way obstructing interfering the natural
course of justice being carried out by
an investigation the clip is stunning it
is only twenty eight seconds but it
contains so much wackiness that I want
you to pay really close attention to
these twenty eight seconds I mean the
reality is Comey
in some ways ends up being a good
witness for us unless you assume they're
trying to get him into a perjury trap by
he tells his version somebody else has a
different version how is he a good
witness for the president if he's saying
that the president was asking directing
him and his words to let the Michael son
investigation go he didn't directly do
that what he said to him was can you can
you give homie because he took it as
directly okay I'm taking it that way I
mean by that time he had been fired and
he said a lot of other things some of
which has turned out to be untrue this
is just completely untrue I mean he's
completely revising the timeline into
one that if my current understanding of
time is moving forward and we can't like
travel back in time or change the past
currently like that's my understanding
and maybe in the future these are things
we'll be able to do I don't think
Giuliani is referring to sort of like a
break in the space-time continuum here
this is not the way it happened Rudy
Giuliani who is Trump's own lawyer is
admitting that during the time when Jeff
bi director James Comey was FBI director
he was told by the president to look at
giving a break to National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn that is direction
when it comes to a specific invest
investigate and it
is obstruction of justice and I know I
know unless Trump is impeached it won't
make a difference you likely can't
indict a sitting president but that
doesn't change whether it's obstruction
and it is and the executive branch
directing the FBI to handle a particular
investigation in a particular way
including being lacks right giving Flynn
a break that is asking for before there
is a an actual indictment before there
is a trial before there is a sentencing
it's saying just give him a break on the
entire thing which which of course at
that phase in the investigation means
maybe let the entire thing go as George
Stephanopoulos points out now remember
this also contradicts that Trump said
when asked this exact same thing last
year that he never said anything like it
to James Comey so Giuliani Trump's
personal lawyer is making this comment
from Trump last year appeared to be
shocker untrue Thank You mr. president
in the light of a very busy news week a
lot of people would like to get to the
bottom of a couple of things give you a
chance to go on record here did you at
any time
urge former FBI director James Comey in
any way shape or form to close or to
back down the investigation into Michael
Flynn and also as you know next question
well his home lawyer Rudy Giuliani is
now saying the opposite and at first
Rudy Giuliani said he was contradicting
Trump remember when he was first hired
by Trump yeah and then he said all sorts
of things that were the opposite of what
Trump said he said well I was just hired
and I'm kind of trying to figure things
out later he was asked about it and he
said well those were just rumors right
rumors created by him apparently he
wrote them off as just rumors what's the
excuse now and I'm not asking
rhetorically I genuinely am wondering
how is it that Rudy Giuliani continues
to directly contradict Trump and is it a
strategy merely to create confusion yeah
why do they keep putting him on the
sunday talk shows I know he had a few
week hiatus yes but you're really gonna
put this guy back he keeps putting his
foot in his mouth and you would have
imagined that was the hiatus during
which he was informing himself about the
relevant facts related to all of this
stuff but apparently not I think in the
end pardons are gonna be flying soon and
none of the
is gonna matter and we like to think in
general that people know what they're
doing but we are aware of these ideas
that 80% of people are incompetent at
what they do
we still imagine that okay even if 80%
of lawyers are sometimes incompetent the
president's lawyers those would be the
best people and maybe that's not the
case unless of course this is and this
is a counter-argument people emailed me
about they said something along the
lines of Rudy Giuliani is contradicting
Trump to obfuscate and confuse so that
no one really knows what's true and
becomes distrustful of everything that
they hear and just kind of give up on
figuring out what's going on which is
less like 1984 by George Orwell but more
like brave new world by Aldous Huxley
that is more reminiscent of what was
laid out by Aldous Huxley which is who
even really knows what's true I'll just
figure out something else to think about
yeah you were talking about the
confusion over when you know if time is
moving forward or backward or what's
going on with that
maybe that's the 40 chests that they're
talking about always yes it's 7
dimensional underwater chess played only
when it's completely dark out between
the hours of 2:00 a.m. and 4:00 a.m. and
somehow they're playing they're playing
the game masterfully or something like
that today's program made possible in
part by Foote or the social forecasting
game where you come together and compete
with other players to predict future
events open up the game on your phone or
web browser you'll see a range of
forecasts politics sports everything in
between you wager the fake in-game
currency on predicting real world events
you win that same currency whenever you
make a prediction that comes true I'm on
food tour you can find my account and
follow me by clicking the link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube this week on food tour I pose
the question it's a good question will
Paul Manafort be sentenced to more than
10 years in prison what do you think
click the link in the description and
make your wagers you can also browse the
politics category to make other
predictions sign up at fut you you are
calm start making forecasts totally free
it's on Android iOS and web browsers
that is futur comm fut you you are
dot-com